Yeah.
Hello and welcome the toxic Google.
I'm Kevin Dog.
I'm Rebecca Prozan and we're here today
to talk about the new movie free held
and we have Ellen page and Julianne Moore.
So, uh, you know this, this story is,
it's a beautiful love story that tells
the story of a true story of a Lowell
Hester, uh, who is a very
decorated, well known,
respected a police
officer, a detective, uh,
in New Jersey and develops lung cancer
and it's stage four and wants to pass her
benefits onto Stacy, uh, her partner
Stacy, and is not allowed to.
So it's about that
struggle and that fight,
trying to get that approval
from the freeholders, this
governing council. So, um,
very, very powerful story. And I
kind of want to talk about, um,
just what led you both to this project.
Sure. Um, okay. Well, when
I was a, a freehold, uh,
there's a documentary with the
same name made by Cynthia Wade,
which is incredible,
and you should check it out and won an
Oscar in 2008 for best short subject.
So shortly after that,
Michael Shamberg and Stacey share
producers on the project sent me the
documentary and asked if I would
like to attach myself to play Stacy.
And I watched it and I was weeping.
I was so moved and I said
yes immediately. Um, and,
and then they were very gracious and
generous and involve me in the development
process.
And so we found why not run a nice one
or about the screenplay and then Pete
solid.
And then Julie.
Yeah,
we're involved for seven years.
You're a producer on the film as well.
So I'm the casting of just Juliane.
So what stage was that then?
That was a, I mean, that was when
we were shooting the film a year ago.
And you said yes in February.
Yeah. So this time last year we were
actually shooting, um, in, in New York,
but yeah,
it was February when I first met
with Pete and talk to Ellen and yeah,
so it wasn't that long ago. Really?
Year and a half or so. Yeah,
I guess there are thousands of same
sex couples that have had similar,
unfortunately some with
situations to this with,
there's something about the story itself
for the documentary when you saw it
that like you just said, like the
light bulb went off in, you're like,
I have to do this. Wow. Well, the
documentary is, is pretty extraordinary.
I think the degree of,
of intimacy with which you
experience it is, is unusual.
The fact that they allowed a documentarian
in their home every single day that
during the last year of
Laurel's life is, is, uh, it's,
it's very unusual. So I think
you, I think you get a, uh,
a palpable sense of who they are and
what they were up against and what,
and how and what screw Urbanation
really means. You know, what, what,
what are the costs of, of, uh,
of something that seems innately political
when you realize that they're talking
about listing their house
and specifically as it relates to
the detective, your character. Um,
she seems like, because
I saw it on Monday, yeah.
That she would be sort of a
difficult character to get to know.
And to learn about, um, she's complex.
Yes. She's a little distant. Um,
she's a cop and not someone who was
necessarily forthcoming about who she is.
How did you wrap your head around that as
an actress? Well, interestingly enough,
the cop part was the hardest part for me.
The relationship part was
easy. I mean, you know, that,
that I understand that's something I think
we're all familiar with, you know, who,
how you fall in love with somebody and
build a life with them. But for me,
being a police officer was
really, really different. And,
and of course I had the Laurel
and the doc, you know, um, and I,
so I had the Laurel who was not well,
but I did not know the Laurel who,
who was healthy. And that was really
provided to me by Stacy Andre herself,
who opened her home to us and showed
us all these newspaper clippings and
photographs and um,
and shared her memories.
And also Dane Wells who was, uh, Laurel's
partner, police partner and boils,
brother and sister.
And so with all of that information,
I was able to kind of figure out
who the, who that Laurel was. And,
and what was interesting
is that, that the, I think,
I think because she was such a,
she was such a police officer,
really believed in justice system,
really believed in doing the right thing,
that kind of moral fiber
or the her ethics. We're,
we're truly what drove her to do the
right thing for the woman that she loves.
And, you know, is there, obviously
this is, you know, based on true story,
these are real characters.
Is there a sense of fear or you know,
real responsibility because
you are adapting and you
are actually acting as real
people who really existed
and do still exist? For sure.
I think we all felt a sense
of responsibility and, um,
you know, wanted, you know,
Stacy and Dane to feel, um,
safe essentially to,
to,
to have them know that our goal is to
make something as truthful and as honest
and as authentic as possible.
Um, and so we always just,
we would text Stacy or,
you know, communicate with
her while we were shooting,
and then she came to sat for a day she's
in, you can see her in the film at, uh,
at the end, at a certain
point. And Yeah. So, um,
I think you feel a sense of responsibility
and that's probably what we put most
of our thought into,
I would say.
Yeah. Yeah. I think you've
touched on this a little bit,
but how involved was she in
the development of the film?
Was she, you know, onset?
Were you asking her for advice?
Like how did that work? She was,
she was really involved. I mean, she a
run nice one or spent a lot of time, uh,
the screen screenwriter with Stacy and
with Dane and with Stephen Goldstein has
Steve Carell plays and, um, and then she,
we both spent a lot of time with
her and she was just so, um,
kind to us. And as you
can imagine, a lot of, uh,
the conversations are
difficult and emotional.
You know the ones about the good times
and the ones about the difficult times
and it's all, um, you know, her having
to bring that back up to the surface.
It's sorta interesting cause she's also
seems unwilling to participate through
the movie. So it's almost sweet that
she, maybe that's not the right word,
but that and compelling that
she was so participatory.
Well I think it truly is a reflection of
her love and dedication towards Laurel
and Cindy Wade when she's making the
documentary. Did ask Laurel, you know,
how would you feel if people
would want to fictionalize this?
Like is that something that you'd be
willing to give the the rights to?
And she was like, as if someone would want
to do that, of course was her response.
But um,
she was absolutely,
I would want as many people as possible
and know about our story and what you
know,
and the community goes through
doing your research, you know, on Laurel
and Stacy and their story and Dane and,
and everything. You know what's
really, you're watching a film,
but you have to keep in the back of
mind that this actually happened.
This is a real story. And what's, what's
really gut wrenching to think too,
is that not only were they fighting cancer
and they were fighting, um, you know,
not just marriage,
gay marriage,
it was marriage equality and they allowed
a documentary film and directly to
come into their lives. So can you
talk about just meeting, you know,
Stacy and talking with them about what
brought that decision and was like, yeah,
we're okay with this, that the last
year of my life, our lives together,
we're going to do this.
It was Dane who really spearheaded it.
I mean,
that's what's interesting is that Dane,
um, I think came into their lives and,
and wanted to have a sense of outrage
about how they were being treated and
wanted to, to make a
difference. And so he had,
he began to organize the press
coverage of, of their fight.
And he was the one that fielded the
calls from film makers and, and he,
he brought Cynthia Wade to them because
he liked the way Cynthia sounded on the,
on her, on his answering
machine. So I think that,
I think probably the least acquiescent
partner was Stacy because she was just
trying to take care of Laurel. Um, but,
but I think that they began to feel
compelled to do the right thing simply
because of what was happening.
But, but I think without Dane,
I don't know that this
all would have happened.
He really was quite heroic and really,
really protective of them.
Their story.
You talked about this earlier to join,
but for both of you,
um,
this movie is about Justice
and Equality and, um,
and really same sex marriage or same
set and rights for same sex couples.
Um, did you think it was interesting
that Laurel said time and time again?
I'm not fighting for marriage.
I'm funding for quality.
I love that about her. I mean, I love
that she to be political about something.
She was like, she was not there to
do what Steven Goldstein wanted,
which they needed.
They both needed each other.
Clearly I'm Laurel and Stacy needed
Stephen Goldstein to bring attention to
their cause and Stephen Goldstein
wanted them to, to, to, uh,
move his agenda forward. And they
knew that. And I think there was that,
there was not, um, it, it was an
uneasy alliance. Would they both,
they both wanted different things. And,
and as I said, the, I think it was,
I think it was Laurel's ethics that
made her say, no, this is, I'm not,
I'm not fighting for a political movement.
I'm fighting for what is fair.
You know, Edie Windsor, sad, you know,
Laurel Hester is a hero for asking to
be treated exactly like everybody else.
So I think that those, I think those
degrees were, were important to her, that,
that distinction that what they,
that legally they should have had this,
it was only a loophole in
the law that allowed the,
the benefits to be decided by the county
core zine just had kind of not close
that loophole.
Yeah. And so, and you know,
it's such a beautiful,
beautiful movie and a great movie where
you're asking people who have these
certain beliefs,
these free holders essentially,
and there's millions of them
like them where it's, it's,
we're not asking you to
even just believe in this.
We're actually asking you
just for your support. Right.
And so it's like we're not
trying to change your beliefs.
If you believe one thing,
that's fine.
So how were they able to succeed in that
with the freeholders where it was like,
you have to accept this?
You know,
I think it was just all the
pressures, pressure every, you know,
when it was happening to
every county around, um,
ocean county. Yeah. You fixed
the loophole. And so that,
and they were just surrounded and the
pressure was strong and they, of course,
I called them and say like,
you know, this is enough.
It's embarrassing. You know? So,
yeah, but it was political. Yeah.
And it's true in the, if you've seen
the film for those who've seen the film,
like for example,
when the,
the certain freeholder like doesn't
show up to the meeting. That was true.
And he was like on vacation,
but he wasn't. And you know,
so it's all very accurate
to what happened.
Um, Ellen, this movie,
it's a powerful statement about changing
hearts and minds and during the seven
years sort of the country changed
with the production of the movie. Um,
polls consistently show more
support for civil rights. Right.
Did that change,
did that see change sort of
change how you marketed the movie?
Thought about who should be in the movie?
Anything about like how it was produced
or anything about, I don't know.
So at all actually. Yeah,
I know. I mean, we were,
we were always trying to make
the movie we're trying to make,
which was an honest, you
know, reflection of their,
their experience and what
has been actually interesting
and watching it even at
the premiere recently,
sort of after, you know,
a lot of the backlash post,
the recent awesome supreme court decision,
there was like all of these sort of new,
there's
definitely new things that I,
I was noticing sort of after a lot of
the dialogue that's been happening.
Um,
but no,
I don't think anything was necessarily
adjusted or changed in any way.
What were some of your favorite scenes
to shoot together and some of the most
toughest ones to, cause
I, you know, there's this,
I love this thing at the
beginning, just the, you know,
hey, can I have your number?
And you know, yeah. Have the writing
on the arm. It's so cute. It's like,
you're like, oh, okay. You know, when you
go there and it's absolutely adorable,
you know, and it's in the tray.
It's, it's great. So what was the,
I mean that's mine, but like what
were your favorite scenes to shoot?
It's about Megan
really.
So what were some of the elements,
but also what were the most complicated?
One's the toughest one. The shoot.
We loved it all. We did. I mean,
honestly, it was such a delight to,
to go to work every day and to have Ellen
there as my partner onscreen and off.
And I think just being
together, um, I never felt,
um, we just, when we were just a team,
you know, so everything felt like a,
something that we were maneuvering.
And we were discovering. Yeah. Yeah.
You really were. But I
mean, that being said,
I always liked the happy stuff better than
the set stuff. Yeah. You know, I love,
my favorite thing was the date,
you know,
where she brings me with a soda
and I have to say, you know,
I'm older than you when she was like, Oh
yeah, whatever. And then we dance and,
and it was just a really fun,
fun, beautiful night. Um,
and we'd gotten to know each other very
well that we shot that near the end of
the shoot. And it was great to shoot
a scene where you're falling in love,
you know, but also not that I'm
trying to run away the conversation,
but also even in the really
emotional stuff to have,
have Ellen there as, as a partner in
that same way, just allowed us to,
to, I don't know, it allow,
we'd had a wonderful shared experience
with it and you when it was tough. Well,
I can tell you they're going to be a lot
of jokes about spike drama for years to
come. Spiked, Huh? Oh yeah.
Yeah. What's funny is I,
I gave that tee shirt to my friends.
But yeah.
How has this movie changed you?
Both of you.
I have a new friend
every meeting. No, I can't, I can't, you
can't say that about every movie. I mean,
I can,
I go to movies and I have,
I can have great relationships
with the people that I work with.
I don't necessarily come away with like
a new friend and I genuinely did on this
one. But I also feel, and this was
something that I was surprised by myself,
that I don't think I have really
a full understanding of what it,
how painful it was to be closeted and
then have to deal with a public to come
out publicly on a, on a, on
a big platform to, you know,
I don't think somebody said to me,
are you kidding?
You must've known lots of people
have come out. And I'm like, yeah,
but a long time ago, I'm old, you know,
everyone's kind of been in
their lives and it's been,
it's been a while since I've
experienced somebody doing it sort of.
So recently in with and,
and, and publicly and
it, and it certainly raised my
awareness and deepen my compassion.
Yeah,
no. When you're on the project
for seven years too, so did, was,
was there a lot of change
with you with that and just,
just your perspective on everything?
Yup.
Yeah. So I mean, when I was attached
to the movie, when I was 21,
I was in very closet. I was
very closeted person, you know,
and be embarrassed to say how
closeted I was. And, um, it is,
I will say it was when I reflect back,
it really does blow my mind.
Like how much my personal story did
correlate in parallel with the development
of this. And that being said,
it would have to, you know,
it feel wildly inappropriate to be
a closeted actor playing this role.
Um, and, um, you know,
more than that, it is,
it's people like Laurlynn Stacy that
inspire you to do the right thing for
yourself,
for your emotional wellbeing and life,
and to be a visible person
for the community. You know,
they dealt with the really horrific
situation and really stood up.
And, uh, what makes,
allows me the privileges that I now have
in my life that shouldn't be taken for
granted.
So.
Yup. And we'll start taking
audience questions if you
guys wanna start lining up.
Um, but you know, another
interesting thing,
I was watching the movie too and then
you have the documentary as well,
but in the development of
it or the writing of it, um,
was there anything that you
want to include it in the
movie but couldn't because
of time constraints or it didn't really
match with the film and it was like,
this is a really,
really important,
or this is a really interesting
part but just doesn't fit.
There was some,
I don't know any,
there were at certain point I
feel like the script is, you know,
it was longer and then you
are limited by your budget.
You're limited by the days
you'll have to shoot, et cetera.
Like I can remember
where you did go to the,
there was a scene where maybe you
haven't even read this telling me
gay audience.
It's just somebody.
Um, so the, the sure there's
things that, you know, you, you get
limited by your resources when you should
have loaded budget movie and only have
what, 26 days to shoot. Yeah.
We'll even like the guys who played the
freeholders I think shot everything in a
day and a half. Yeah. We're thinking, man,
that's horrible. This poor guys, you know,
so they barely had a chance to, to, to,
to really get going on something we
didn't have any time. You just use,
wish you had more time. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
[inaudible] not at, won't ask you a
question about the movie, but Ellen, um,
there are still deeply entrenched,
uh,
beliefs about same sex marriage
and equality and LGBT rights.
What did you learn in your interaction
with Ted Cruz now that you've had a
chance to reflect on it?
What did I learn?
What did you learn in terms of the
perspective of someone that you know,
that a lot of us in this
room probably disagree with
pretty deeply? Like, did you,
did you learn anything about that
perspective or is just you just disagree
with them? Oh No. You know,
I've been making sure with vice that
will come out early next year where I've
been,
I'm traveling around the world and going
to different countries and exploring
the LGBT community in which the country
we've been in different countries.
Um, so I've had a year of
these kinds of conversations.
Typically they're more sit
down conversations with
people on a really extreme,
uh, most of it of course, is focused on
the community and people in the community.
But yes,
we do address those and have conversations
with people who are think drastically
different. And I mean, very,
very extreme to, um, you know,
less extreme. And, um, so it's, it's,
you know, it's hard. It's hard.
I think sometimes too, when I'm,
when it's a politician,
because you don't,
you're not gonna you struggle. They get
to have a real conversation. You know,
how awesome is it that we
live in a country where I
can walk up at a state fair
and have a conversation with a
senator, would totally, you know,
speaks to me and gives me the, gives me
the time. But you know, I think it's,
it's what happened with Ted Cruz is,
um, the outcome was what I expected.
You know,
I've seen Ted Cruz be asked questions
regarding the community before and it's a
similar sort of a, it tends
to be like, you know, uh,
evasive flower rhetoric
and distance from one,
you know, answering a direct
question, shall we say. So it's,
it's hard to, it's hard
to, I don't know. And it's,
it's always a similar rhetoric no
matter where I've been. It's the same,
the same things are said to you no
matter what, where you are in the world.
So, um, hey guys,
so I guess I actually watched the movie
a few days ago and there were definitely
some scenes that were
super like cringeworthy,
especially the ones that involved the
freeholders on in a room, you know,
like saying that they wanted a unanimous
vote and like you heard the entire
audience gas when these things
happen because they were so terrible.
And it really got me wondering how
difficult it was to cast roles as such.
Or like find people who believed in like
the, the message of the film so much,
but had to play these terrible,
terrible roles of like being these people
who are so negative against Laurel and
Stacy. So if you have insight
on that, that'd be really cool.
I think. Not Hard at all. I mean,
and we were fortunate because we were
shooting in New York and so that you have
access to all these incredible New
York actors who live there and who are
interested in doing, you
know, important movies.
And so everybody, all of those guys
that, they all have amazing resumes,
they've all done a lot of theater and
I think they were interested in the
project itself.
So I don't know that it was,
it was difficult for them
to play somebody who, um,
it was espousing of view that
was different from their own.
I don't think that it was, I think
that they were, I think they were
intrigued to be part of a,
of a bigger story, you know?
And I think that's what we've found with,
with our entire cast.
And they were there because they really
believed in the film. Cool. All right.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm so, I also saw the movie on
Monday and was just incredibly moved.
So thank you so much for,
you know,
bringing this important story to the big
screen. It means the world. Um, Julianne,
I wanted to ask,
this is I think your fifth time
portraying a queer woman in a movie
and you've even,
and I think that's super
awesome and interesting.
And I just wanted to ask you how your
identity as an ally has kind of evolved,
you know, through the process
of portraying queer women.
Well, um, you know
what
I always say is that it's
interesting that that the, my Rez,
I've made like 60 something
movies, right? And so, um, and,
and of all the characters I've played,
so I played maybe if, you know,
five gay characters or whatever,
but that's not even the,
the percentage of the
population that is gay.
So it's always interesting to me or so
we know, we don't even really know. Um,
that's according to a report that
was given from the 50s. So, um,
so it's interesting,
probably accurate.
That's, yeah. No, but I
think is not accurate.
I think there's probably more of
this what I'm saying under, Oh yeah.
But anyway,
I
interesting to me that so many people
in media will point that out to me all,
I played so many characters and I'm like,
I don't even think, yeah, I just don't,
I'm just, I don't, I don't even find
that notable because for, for me,
every time I've been
attracted to a character,
it's just because of who they are
and their sexuality has been, um,
beside the point.
But that being said,
it is interesting that every time
I am talking about something,
I ended up kind of in the,
in the middle of LGBT, um,
discussions and politics and,
and you can't help but evolve
when you are exposed to, um,
to so many discussions and so many
personalizations to people saying what,
you know,
what kind of skirmishes they've,
they've experienced and their
difficulties and what it's like to be, um,
to be out or to be closeted or whatever.
So I do.
I do think it has grown my
awareness and hopefully, um,
my compassion and made me a better
ally. Awesome. Thank you. Um,
thank you guys so much for being here.
We appreciate it,
Huh?
The end.
[inaudible]
right now. So thank you guys so much
and go see it. Thank you. Thank you. Hi.